läuft und ich schreibe jetzt gerade noch
sich die zusagen die letzten texte für
mein neues crowe das kinderbuch ist
jetzt endlich fertig das ist auch schon
zum druck freigegeben
jetzt fehlen nur noch ein paar texte
eben für das türkische kochbuch und das
setzt sich gerade noch dran morgen
geht's leider schon wieder nach hause
ich muss sagen das schöne wetter
wahrscheinlich sehr vermissen und auch
meine eltern aber die kommen auch direkt
eine woche nach uns wieder nach hause
und so dass wir wieder vereint sind
was ich sagen wollte nächste woche am
samstag also genau in einer woche werde
ich auf der ifa in berlin sein und zwar
ist es die internationale
funkausstellung und da bin ich dann am
stand von bosch und werde dort dann am
samstag zu den tag verteilt immer mal
wieder koch shows machen und dann habt
ihr einfach zeit euch mit mir zu
unterhalten
beziehungsweise ich hatte zeit mich mit
euch zu unterhalten ihr könnt mir fragen
stellen
es gibt kostenlose getränke muratow
besorgt steht auch gern mache jeder das
was er tun kann und die ich falsch
riesig die ifa ist riesig ich habe es
auch noch nie geschafft muss ich echt
sagen komplett mal überall rumzulaufen
ich hoffe dass ich dieses jahr ein
bisschen weiter kommen als nur eine
halle
wenn ich werde auch noch einen rundgang
machen das ganze auch für euch mit
aufnehmen
aber wie gesagt ich bin am samstag am
stand von bosch und werde da kochen und
backen beispielsweise jetzt habe ich gar
nicht geguckt aber ich werde auf jeden
fall unten rein schreiben
und ja ich freue mich das schon sehr
drauf das ist schon wieder ein jahr in
berlin waren richtig sind wahrscheinlich
käme wieder ins in diesen tischen im
letzten jahr an ifa berlin war richtig
lustig
ein kamerateam kommt mit und ja das ist
auch im prinzip so unsere erste
baustelle wieder nach dem urlaub
apropos baustelle baustellen updates
gibt es übrigens auch bald wieder so
bald wieder zu hause sind um sich
natürlich überhaupt was auf der
baustelle getan hat also ich hoffe es
natürlich sehr und dann werden wir euch
informieren
30 karten vergessen die karten genau wie
viel hast du versorgt 25 02 karten 25 x
2 karten
das heißt ihr könnt noch 25 mal zwei
karten gewinnen für die war
dafür könnt ihr jetzt einfach eine
e-mail schreiben und zwar an gewinn als
alice welt.de und dann werdet ihr
benachrichtigt falls ihr die karten
gewonnen habt ansonsten gibt's die
fahrkarten die non stop motion zwischen
sie müssen zwischen 9 und 13 euro kosten
die karten
bitte meldet euch wirklich nur für die
karten bin ja auch wirklich sicher sein
dass sie kommt und ansonsten gibt es
aber auch noch
natürlich jeden tag an der eper
tageskarten zu kaufen also man kann auch
direkt vor ort eintrittskarten holen und
ja ich würde mich sehr freuen wenn er
vorbei kommt und wenn ich euch kennen
lernen kann
essen und getränke war gesorgt
die geburtstagsgrüße schonach katja
viele vielen dank für euren
geburtstagsgrüße vielen dank für die
tollen videos die ich bekommen habe für
die ganzen kommentare für die e mails
ich habe muss ich sagen noch nicht alle
gelesen weil als ich bin immer am lesen
aber noch nicht alle
und ja vielen vielen herzlichen dank das
war wirklich sehr schön wir waren mit
meiner familie und das könnte auf
facebook das kann ich ja facebook
anschauen
leider war der empfang so schlecht und
es facebook live video waren von der
qualität her nicht so super genau
also ich freu mich auf nächste woche auf
samstag am 2
september will ich auf dem stand von
bosch auf der ifa und ich freue mich auf
euch
bis dann wenn es der meldefrist
gewinnspiel und die woche drauf du
deinen freiburg leitet sich
durcheinanderbringen
nächste woche nächste woche samstag als
in einer woche in berlin
macht's gut macht's gut so jetzt kann
man hochladen
er passt leider war es ein von katja
[Musik]
kraus nein ich habe es noch den knopf zu
drücken
nein habe ich nicht mehr spaß